you have an interesting perk that yes
well the fun thing about kick-started
your perks and so people can pledge as
low as a dollar you know and be part of
the part of our team or and kick start
lashing up to ten thousand dollars so
people get you know walk-ons in the
movie you know all sorts of stuff and
you know that watches and jackets and
your name of books and photos and
posters but we also design on a website
perks that go from fifteen thousand
dollars up to half a million and it was
very fun designing those rewards and
when we got up to 250 250 thousand
there's a very fun thing which is one of
inspirations for Space Command is a
great TV show called Space Patrol it was
on from 1952 1955 live television I
actually met the star of that show at
camera who was quite wonderful a
wonderful man lemon head writer norm
jolly and they had the best contest ever
which was to the kid who named the tenth
planet planet x they the winner of that
contest got a full-sized copy of their
spaceship it was a 35 foot long
spaceship made out of steel and aluminum
delivered on a flatbed truck it was
bigger than the kids parents house okay
but locally the 10 year olds were worn
it and so in honor of that contest at
$250,000 someone will get our entire
spaceships set it'll be delivered on a
flatbed truck to the winner but then you
think what's what can we do to beat that
well in half a million one could
tailgate for half a million bucks
500,000 and we said okay here we go they
get first of all to get a red carpet
premiere in their hometown so they can
invite all their friends plus they get
an actual trip into space a real trip so
there are a number of carriers now
offering an actual trip into space
legitimate carriers and so they'll get a
ticket on one of those spaceships so
that's pretty cool so if someone's just
sitting around the house thinking about
what to do with that half million that
they don't need please you know go on to
you know with our space command website
and
I can roll
you